this incredible colorful city will only
last a few months but for one local
designer the seasonal spectacular is
worth it Jin and Zhang is an
award-winning ice sculptor and art
teacher in Harbin China carbine is known
as the city of ice and each year host
the incredible spectacle the Harbin snow
and ice festival these large-scale
designs are remarkable but it's quite a
process one Jean Ann knows well Filipino
alarum bulldozers Polly Sergey - genki
jungle sahaja yogi whattodo whattodo
whattodo quantum logic iris Nene callin
me Anita hope yo te Oh Tony maws of all
from India Otto pinatas revolver
Umizoomi American to Allah joseline la
la la Sierra cannibalism
Alicia so my sonogram to war against
ployment
so don't only way to fly while the
tourism economy need to a party no need
calculus tournament event will not
charlie
filling the video sweet practice so it's
always no quick you might say I feel so
duster Hall starting with a block of
plain ice may seem daunting but to Jean
Ann this is just the beginning
Lyngen lion equal to four Myanmar Sri
Linga may sue what actually the city and
go wake up a little game or share a
human don't agility show you the
tumbling up village or two most
commercially Anagha kannada come here
killer so very colonel here the mostly
yeah Vargas lee jong-kul oh what a
hoodie thank you but the reality of
working with a seasonal medium has its
downfalls convenient your own wallet oh
what Oh Brady Chicana doctor yet renew
each other haven't even touched on will
go hogs with him
[Music]